hey what's up welcome to ask AJ the only
question and answer show well you
actually probably don't ever get a real
answer
let's try that again
hi guys welcome to new episode of ask IJ
I've got so many questions that I just
don't even know what to do with them all
so let's start answering you don't know
what dailybooth is have you been hiding
under a rock have you been hiding under
a pillow wherever you've been hiding
come on out because there's a new
website and its called dailybooth you
take a little picture of yourself and
then other people can photo comment and
comment back in response it's really
really fun so that's why I decided to
add a new daily booth segment get to ask
IJ quick Steve wants to know why I
frequently take photos and videos in
front of my couch what are you talking
about Lukie 24 wants to know if I could
have any accent which way would I have
but obviously I'd have this accent I
can't when you think of having any other
honestly I would just like to go to the
grocery store and be like hello I'm at
the store where is your milk
I was just wondering where all the dairy
products here at this grocery store the
most important to me so I really enjoyed
this Twitter question by slow G slow I
don't know how to pronounce your screen
name but anyway you asked what was my
most embarrassing moment well probably
one of my most embarrassing moments was
when I was in high school and I have
this special talent that I can trip and
not get hurt
so all my friends knew this if they said
you see hey it's lunchtime were in the
cafeteria
it'll be so funny if you trip and fall
and throw all of your books in the air
well it was really funny at the time
except when I was caught into the
principal's office
control that I was inciting a riot in
the cafeteria and then I got detention
the ever so famous what's your favorite
food question now I probably wouldn't
advance this question since you guys
already know all of my favorite foods
but my top favorite food is a grilled
cheese sandwich now I have a funny video
to go along with this my sister and I
were to eat in Park last week and we
decided to see if I could throw up her
cheese up in the air and catch the whole
thing in my mouth to see if I actually
accomplished this task
head on over to my YouTube cons other
iJustine channel and watch the whole
video
Oh video responses this girl says the
best gets bad but yes I've got it yeah I
just Eames I just Steen gotta get that
by just doing video spots yes I J I have
a question for human wife do you have a
question no are you sure
hi J if you could tell me what does IJ
stand for my real question is how do you
get a song out of your head you can't
get it out of your head I have a song in
my head I cannot get it out do you have
any suggestion the song
Wow um how do you even answer a question
like that
I don't know I'm speechless
that's the frost guy Jay make sure you
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already and I'll see you guys in the
next episode